أريد أن أسألك هذا لأن
بعض آخر الأخبار هي أن الرئيس ترامب
كما نعلم قد أجرى مكالمة هاتفية
مع الحاكم وخرج بعض هذا
الصوت ونحن
نستخدمه وفيه يقول للحاكم يقول لك
إنه ضعيف ، كما يقول ، يجب أن
يعرف الكثير منكم عدم إظهار هذا الضعف ، فنحن
نضحك عليك أن تهيمن
عليك أن تهيمن ، أريد أن أطلب منك
ألا تفعل إذا كنت لا تريد التعليق على
رئيس الولايات المتحدة  ولكن هذا هو
الاتجاه الصحيح للشرطة اليوم في
هذه البيئة للخروج والسيطرة
وإظهار أنهم ليسوا إقتباسًا
ضعيفًا ، فما الذي يجب
أن تفعله الشرطة الآن لتهدئة هذا الوضع الرهيب ،
دعني أقول هذا فقط
للرئيس  من الولايات المتحدة نيابة
عن رؤساء الشرطة في هذا البلد ، من
فضلك إذا لم يكن لديك شيء
بنّاء لتقوله أبق فمك مغلقًا
لأنك تعرض الرجال والنساء في
أوائل العشرينات من العمر للخطر ، فهذا لا
يتعلق بالسيطرة بل يتعلق بالفوز
قلوب و  العقول ودعونا نكون واضحين ،
لا نريد أن يخلط الناس بين
اللطف والضعف ، لكننا لا نريد
أن يقوم الجهلاء بالتجذير لإفساد ما لدينا هنا في
هيوستن والتحدث نيابة عن زملائي في
جميع أنحاء البلاد حيث
يُصاب ضباطهم بأفراد المجتمع
تتعرض للإصابة إذا لم يكن لديك
ما تقوله مثل Forrest Gump
ولا تقل ذلك لأن هذا هو العامل
الأساسي للقيادة ونحن بحاجة إلى
القيادة الآن أكثر من أي وقت مضى